Tucker Carlson says RFK Jr will pull
votes from Trump not Biden there's no
person who's thinking I'm G to vote for
either Joe Biden or Bobby Kennedy and
Tucker is wrong yeah he's definitely
he's absolutely wrong on this I think
this is more of a passive statement he
made speaking on a podcast because it
does not seem like he actually looked at
the data or had real conversations I
think Ian's a good example because Ian's
talked about how his mom is a big fan of
the kennedies yeah yeah she loved uh
Bobby and she would never vote for Trump
no I don't think so so this maybe she
met him this is a perhaps this is a very
simple piece of math it's probability
let's say uh your mom's probability of
voting for Biden is 80% and voting for
Kennedy is 20% and voting for Trump is
0% that's the kind of math where if you
have enough of those people it can only
pull from from Joe Biden it can never
pull from Trump I remember when uh
Robert Kennedy announced he was going to
Robert Kennedy Jr announced he was going
to run for president within like 3 days
they slandered him or smeared him with
antivaxx on the news and I called my
mother like right away and I was like
hey watch out for this antia crap
they're going to start calling him now
that he announced and she's like yeah
but I don't know I just don't know how I
feel about I'm like dude two years ago
she was saying how much she loves Robert
Kennedy Jr and it's like the news
started to get to her right away so
there might be something there where
they're they're tainting people's
opinion of the guy he's going to pull
he's going to pull from both of the the
parties I believe 100 yeah but it's
going to be it's going to be 65 from
Democrats and 30 from Republicans if if
that I I just got to say man I've not
met a single person who said who who who
who will say publicly I'm voting for
Trump who has now been like well I'm
going to vote for AR Kane's dead well oh
you go ahead I was say there was um a
poll done in New Hampshire a couple
weeks ago maybe a month and it was
asking people you know who you're voting
for whatever else we saw that Chris
Chrissy was intensely unpopular there
but uh when they asked about RFK he did
have really high support from Republic
an but none of the Republicans plan to
vote for him and none of them plan to
vote for them vote for him if their
first choice candidate left right it
doesn't change the fact they like him
Republicans are excited that he's in the
race But ultimately his support is still
among Democrats and we saw that when he
announces independ bit it still leaned
left in the language I believe that if R
RFK and this is a wild conspiracy theory
that's not going to come true it's this
theoretical but if RFK was to drop
entirely and start trying to run as
Donald Trump's vice president I think
that that he could get that I believe
talk about RFK Jr is pro reparations pro
gun control Eco fascism I don't yeah I
mean he's big he's big time we've talked
about Trump RFK in the past but this was
only in the context of the the coid
response as a means of helping correct
the image of Trump's failures on it but
now rfk's pivoted in recently much more
heavily especially with reparations and
is an on his Ann uh at his announcement
he said it's indigenous people's day it
was Columbus
but right right he he's he's jumped off
also talked about government backed
bonds to save the housing market I mean
this guy's just like he's a
run-of-the-mill progressive that's good
on the healthcare and the Deep State I
mean really
trat give him a c he might be like in
charge of the EPA or something right if
he really wanted to be like no I know
you guys like him it's exciting but I
don't see him I saw it be floated around
attorney general too yeah yeah maybe I
mean I think it's just not a close
enough Bond I'm sure there's probably
some sort of respect there for you know
whatever cordial reason but I don't
think that there is a close enough uh
camaraderie between the two of them and
also I think Trump's going to be really
careful about who he picks for his VP
because look at what happened with Mike
pen right right I mean he picked someone
who he thought was neutral and that
ultimately ended very badly he's only
going to be a four-year president if
he's elected and that's uh he needs
someone who's really going to back the
fly was a better BP than Mike Pence for
sure so yeah yeah Pence was such a did
you guys see did you guys see the poll
on Twitter that was Chris christe or a
hogy sandwich and the hogy sandwich beat
him like 69% I'm hungry it was hilarious
it was I'll take the hog there was like
there was like 30,000 votes on there and
and the hogy beat him like almost 70%
of' be a good interview cuz chrisy is
the most path you might end up seeing
him sit across from you so be care
whatever you say say it to his face he
keeps doing this Donald Duck thing oh
ter yeah dude it is the cringest thing
cuz he's so excited when he says it on
the debate stage he's like Donald Doc
and then everyone's like you're an idiot
yeah he wants to be Donald Trump so bad
like he really does he wants to be able
to insult people like that he's just not
quick enough cuz he's to overweight man
if he was thin and healthy he would have
a way better chance a lot more people
would like thin and healthy he wouldn't
be funnier if Donald if Donald Trump was
in a one-on-one debate with Christie and
Christy was like this guy Donald keeps
ducking all these questions he's Donald
Duck Trump would go you're fat and
that's it and everyone would go roaring
take care yourself that's all it would
take that's it that's all it would take
absolutely 100% it's all he would say
cuz Trump has no has no filter at all
zero breathing in the microphone exactly
yep he'd say something like that he he
would make that face and
go Lord over he can hear him breathing
and then everyone just busts out
laughing and he's done Donald Duck is
not funny it's not clever it's stupid
and Trump would just do the most crass
bottom of the barrel yeah and you're fat
yeah and then everyone would start
roaring with laughter like all would
take I've I have seen Trump rallies I
have seen that man speak he's a standup
comedian the shut up silly woman thing
is over the Internet still to this day
that you'd be in jail
one shut up silly woman yeah that's all
over that's all over the Internet still
Hillary did you say that to Hillary no
he was a rally and he was telling a
story yeah it was a
rally yeah I I I if you've not seen a
rally this is what I hear from people
they were like I wasn't a big Trump fan
and I decided to go to his rally and now
I'm a trump fan like because the guy
you're going to a comedy routine man
he's doing what John Stewart basically
did back in the day he up there and he's
saying he I'll give you the formula it's
like you got problem I know about
problem I'm going to insult the people
who make problem and everyone starts
cheering for it I kind of like and he
does it well watching old Trump videos
cuz you his personality like you see who
he was when he was young you see who he
is now I think it's a lot you get a
better like more well-rounded idea of
who he is super cool Shane Gillis can
literally go up on stage and impersonate
Donald Trump verba him yeah and the
whole crowd dies laughing and he's just
saying what Trump said that's it exactly
verba
and and Shane Gil's like one of the best
standup comedians in the world right now
yeah so I I I tell you like the key to
getting your your friends and family to
go over the line on like I don't know
about Trump they complain about whatever
just come with me and see what he says
and they're going to leave feeling great
well I don't want you to vote for Trump
though so oh I know you don't but I'm
saying for people like when when you
actually see the guy it's the
entertainment value that he's making you
have a good time this is like a kind of
this is a little bit of an off off
tangent metaphor but like the whole mean
tweets thing they're like instead of a
guy with Mean Tweets I'd rather have a
warmonger it's kind of like on YouTube
we can talk about death and destruction
and and that but we can't say the FW I
mean you can obviously say it but like
what the FW is like the Mean Tweets of
the internet censorship like yo bro I'm
not sure what FW you're talking about
there's a lot of funny ones Fanny oh
okay uh sorry
Australians anyway that we say the f
word on on break the cycle all the time
so I love you were saying before we
started the show that Charisma is one of
the deciding factors in it's very
important can't be a presidential
candidate without it's a giant
popularity contest most important thing
Trump like how how you Define wit right
like what's what's like the colloquial
it's just a quick it's a quick brain I
mean it really what it is quick enough
it's quick enough to equip with people I
mean back and forth you don't need to be
super intelligent and articulate you
need only be quick with it so like the
point I was making with Chris chrisy
being like Donald Duck and then Trump
going I can hear fatsu over here
breathing in the microphone and it's
it's not the smartest thing in the world
but it it's it's a ver he knows how and
when to say things exactly it's it's a
timing thing it'sing issue I think it's
intelligence it requires like at least
16 intelligence the thing the thing the
thing about on a maximum of what the
thing about politics the thing about 18
is maximum human potential and then you
become super human above that sorry
interrup no I no it's fine I was
interrupting you I was literally
interrupting you no I I so the the thing
is is like in politics you only have to
have like a minor understanding of most
issues and then be charismatic enough to
talk about those issues because the the
vast majority of the American public has
no idea what these issues mean anyways
at
allo this is the Aleppo moment in a
nutshell yeah when uh Gary Johnson was
asked about Aleppo and he goes and what
is Aleppo it's just Charisma won right
and then everyone all anyone saw was
this guy doesn't know anything about
what he's about what's going on he could
have he could have said he could have he
could have made up nonsense he could
have said well you know the economic
standard with Aleppo is is is is
troubling to me to be honest but we're
going to we're going to get a policy in
place in Washington it's going to solve
that problem they go wait what but the
average person would be like oh
okay because they just needed to have an
answer the other part about that is it's
a city in Syria by the way it makes him
seem like he's not surrounded by people
who are saying these are the most
important issues because we all know a
president gets you know an intense
number of briefs and theoretically
they're surrounded by experts on each
I'll tell you the biggest the biggest
problem with Libertarians literally this
is the biggest problem is we are all
extremely well read at libertarian
philosophy we've read Murray rothbart
and Fa hyek and misus and all these
great economists and Austrian econ
economists and philosophers and just
everything you could possibly imagine
Henry Haslett and blah blah blah blah
blah and then you want to go out and you
want to lecture this to people and no
one cares literally no one cares they
want to hear about how you're going to
make their cash prices go down that's
what they care about I just wanted to
clarify too because I I wasn't sure on
that it's not the capital is it not the
capital capital I own Damascus that's
right I thought it was Damascus but you
said that I was like let me double check
before I it's Damascus one thing that
Libertarians a problem they have too I
think is that they're not like obsessed
with global Military like you got to be
in order to be a great
commander-in-chief of our military you
got to understand like how are we going
to dominate and annihilate everything on
Earth so we don't have to no but we're
not going to do that we're not but you
have to know how so that you don't so
you know how not to would' be much we'd
be a much safer Nation if our you know
two-thirds of our military wasn't
stationed around the world sure if the
president doesn't understand it if the
president's not a military expert then
someone else is going to run the milit
true the thing is they just have to know
enough about it and have the the reality
is whoever is the president may be
really well versed on a couple issues
right they might have let's say five
that they know backwards forwards they
know everything about but realistically
they're going to need a staff that is
able to yeah that that relies on
expertise and is able to brief them
quickly and so that's why you know when
Gary Johnson gets the Aleppo question
wrong it means he did not have anyone
around him to say this is a current
issue that you should know about and
that's one of the problems going forward
I mean this was a criticis some people
had of trump when he was in the White
House was that the people he surrounded
himself with did not look out for his
best interest and maybe were not guiding
him in the right direction it's
unrealistic to expect a president to
know absolutely everything yeah but a
lot of that was his fault too because he
he was going to drain the swamp and then
he surrounded himself with the swamp I'm
not saying it wasn't But ultimately this
is a problem that could be true for a
Libertarian president it could be true
for a Democrat president it is not
actually the person on stage who knows
everything as the people they're
surrounding themselves with yeah
president does have generals but the
commander must know milary Doctrine or
at least rapidly learn it upon but under
that in that logic we would only want
people who had served in the military to
be presidents which could be true in
some Aras right but theoretically right
now I mean as far as I know Joe Biden
didn't serve in the military maybe he'll
tell us something different uh Trump
went to military boarding school right
but he didn't actually serve in the
military so theoretically both of these
people have
the yeah when was the last time we had a
military commander like a milit
ex-military guy or woman guy George Bush
was it George Bush was he in the
military the firster the dad you mean HW
weren't they both in the mil they were
both in mil but W wasn't wasn't his
story that he didn't go to Vietnam or
something something like that but he was
in the military I mean was it how far
back are we going air did Clinton serve
in the military not that I know of no
Clinton was in the military we have to
work backwards Reagan was a movie star J
Kennedy Kennedy definely was in the Navy
I think in Vietnam and he received I was
he like he wasn't purple heart but he
received like some very serious award
for saving people yeah literally he like
saved a bunch of dudes off a what a
sinking ship or some crazy story that be
a great story served in the Navy during
World War II George Bush George George
HW Bush served in the Navy thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 pm and become a
member over at Tim cast.com for
uncensored membersonly shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next
time